In the last video we spoke about the genesis of data: what place the analysis
of data occupies in business intelligence and strategy and what it
means for practitioners. In this video we are going to take a deeper look at
the motivation behind some of the analytical practices that we are going
to learn in this course. As a quick recap remember that these four stages are the
stages of the data cycle: generation, acquisition, analysis and consumption. We
had spoken about how everybody consumes analysis but very inefficiently. Let's
take a deeper look at why that happens and what we can do to fix it. To
begin with first and foremost most analysts have a habit of simply
reporting their analysis as plain bare facts. We usually don't take the effort
of weaving these facts together in a story like narrative. Now why is this
important? Because stories are what people remember. Facts on the other hand
are bits of information that people are likely to forget. Of course we are not
suggesting that facts are not important, quite the opposite in fact, but they have
to be presented as stories. There is a very good reason why slogans, poems and
joomlas are more effective in, say, political rhetoric than plain bare facts.
As an example there is this website called significantobjects.com on which
Rob Walker and Joshua Glenn tried to sell a bunch of common objects. What they
did differently was that they paid a few writers to write short stories about
these objects. So for example this is an object called Thai hooks and you know
there is a fairly elaborate story written about that. And they found out
that objects which had stories behind them were likely to be sold at a much
higher rate than the ones that just had an item description. So if you were to
quantify the impact of stories on these sales, note that in this particular quick
case they had a return of more than 3000%. In summary, stories are what
people share and remember. But we as analysts have a very different problem.
At the outset let me acknowledge that data analysis is really hard. Not
everybody can do it effectively and because it is difficult we tend to
cling to every single piece of analysis we perform even if some of it may not
help the point we're trying to make. Even if some of it is not what the audience
asked for. Secondly remember that your audience will almost never be able to
replicate the nuances of data analysis. So it is not your analysis that is likely
to impress your audience but the story that you weave around it. Now analysis may
be hard but a lot of it is also a fairly mechanical process. What you do with one
data set you just have to sit down and do with another data set. What you do
with a particular column or a given set of numbers you just have to sit down
and do the same with another set of numbers. You draw charts and then you
replicate that chart for other data sets. That's what I mean when I say that
analytics can become somewhat mechanical. There's always an element of repetition
to it and it is for this reason that many self-service business intelligence
tools are trying to automate the most routine parts of data analysis. Excel,
Power BI and Tableau are all self-service business intelligence tools
which only ask the user to click and point, drag and drop elements onto the
dashboards which reflect your analytics. And since these tools are cheap the rate
at which companies build dashboards has grown exponentially. Building dashboards
is easier and cheaper than ever before. And it's easy to make the dashboard look
pretty even if it doesn't convey anything meaningful. That's why it's very
easy to lose track of how many dashboards we generate and what they do.
This is a major problem that troubles a lot of companies that use self-service
BI tools. But there are three major problems with most dashboards.
It is usually not clear what question a dashboard answers. In fact we don't even
know if there is a question that the dashboard is attempting to answer. To
figure it out you have to look at each individual chart or graphic on the
dashboard and interpret it. That is not easy. Secondly the answer is not obvious
from the dashboard. Very rarely do we find a dashboard that tells us exactly
what we need to know. In fact often the analyst who creates a dashboard has to
painstakingly, at length explain what the dashboard is trying to say. Interpreting
a dashboard without talking to the analyst who created it is often very
difficult. Actually if there is one thing you take away from this course let it be
this: Do not be that person who creates complicated dashboards and then becomes
a bottleneck when it comes to the interpretation of those dashboards. Let
your work speak for itself. Finally the biggest problem with dashboards is that
they don't make it very clear as to what action you should take based on the
inference you draw from the dashboard. That is often left as an exercise to the
reader. Which means that after spending a lot of time and money on analyzing
data the user still has to do their own data interpretation. In other words
dashboards tend to be descriptive rather than prescriptive. And what can be more
prescriptive than stories? After all every story has a moral and that moral
is what tells you what action the user should take. But this is not a new idea.
We have been telling stories with data for a very long time. What you see here
is called a Nightingale Rose chart. It is basically a circular bar chart which was
first created by Florence Nightingale, the lady with the lamp. In addition to
being a nurse she was also a statistician. As you can see the title here
it's the diagram of the causes of mortality. She started collecting data
on why and how soldiers died during the Crimean War. And if you look at the
description the pink area here represents the number of soldiers who
died because of battlefield wounds. And the gray area outside represent soldiers
who died because of infectious diseases. Infections that were
contracted not in the war but in the hospitals which were overflowing with
wounded soldiers. And we can see that nowadays we are seeing a fairly similar
trend with the COVID pandemic. We have hospitals overflowing with COVID patients
and that is where people who have non-COVID problems also are having a
difficult time getting admitted. So broadly what happened is that Florence
Nightingale demonstrated that more people were dying because of infections
rather than because of their battlefield wounds. She took this chart to the Queen
of England with a very clear message that you need to be spending more on
hospitals than military supplies. And she walked out with funding. Imagine what
would have happened if she had let the Queen interpret all this chart by herself.